folks i love you you gotta know that
before we get started i want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by the ridge wallet ridge
wall it's a new smaller sleeker style
type of wallet that's meant for you to
be able to ditch your old bulky wallet
for size comparison
there you go holds up to 12 cards inside
holds cash on the back it's small sleek
discreet fits right in your front pocket
comes in over 30 colors including carbon
fiber and titanium
durable and that durability means it
comes with a lifetime warranty and the
ridge team is in fact so confident in
their product you can get it
try it out for 45 days if you're not
satisfied you can return it full refund
so whether you're looking for a new
wallet or
father's day is coming up so if your
dad's looking for a new wallet or if his
wallet makes this sound when he opens it
well click the link below go to
ridge.com john's enter promo code john's
get yourself 10
off your ridge wallet and thank you once
again to ridge wallet for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it and now cruella
not quite so deville
so cruella's another live-action disney
movie
origin story of a disney villain that
they make a likable
and sympathetic character stars emma
stone as cruella deville i mean not at
first she she has another
name i don't remember it i'm not gonna
google it she comes from nothing she's
generally speaking in this world a
nobody but she has a natural talent for
fashion emma thompson becomes her boss
and she's like the queen of the fashion
world
so really these two go toe-to-toe
essentially oliver twist
meets devil wears prada meets ocean's
three
part heist movie also there's a few
different a lot of cogs in here
quite the mishmash of genres and
properties in here but
emma stone was great in the movie in
fact emma stone and emma thompson both
carry this whole thing i was thinking
about this movie partly because
the movie is an interesting premise that
i don't think had to be a cruella
deville origin
story there's enough enjoyment in this
movie seeing this person who comes from
nothing
but a natural talent in the fashion
world clash
with this titan of the fashion world but
i imagine it just points to the paradigm
we're in when it comes to cinema when it
comes to movies because
i wouldn't be surprised if this movie
was actually meant to be
some other movie the disney was like
great um
we'll make it if we can make it a
superhero movie or a disney property
movie with one of our characters
that's the only way it's happening i
will say the movie's a bit too long not
just a bit too long
it's too long by a large margin this
movie didn't have to be that long it's
two hours and 15 minutes or something
like that
it's you know it's gonna be 15 minutes
of credit so we'll say two hours hour
and a half hour 45 minutes
would have been fine and it feels too
long because you have a few premises
working in here most movies you can say
oh it's this movie meets that movie and
they went splat and it makes this movie
this movie is this and that and that
it's
it's three movies that i just mentioned
i'm sure there's a fourth in there that
i didn't see there's a lot going on in
this movie
and the premise is actually pretty
simple so it feels kind of padded but
it's like they were like no we have to
have all this so people understand
why cruella deville doesn't really feel
like cruella deville by the end of this
because cruella's is persona that emma
stone's character adopts so she can
actually
contest with the baroness but when she
adopts this cruella persona it doesn't
feel earned you know she's this really
meek person and then she's like oh i'm
cruella
and i can just do this now i'm burning
with the confidence of a thousand sons i
have my cane i have my british accent
i'm toe to toe with emma thompson it's
like you're not freaked out at all i get
you know it's it it feels like a mask to
you and that's how acting is and maybe
you're hiding behind that persona i get
it
but you can't tell me she didn't throw
up before doing this because
you know nerves but you never feel like
she has nerves it's like on a flip she's
like nope i'm just a really confident
person i went from
no confidence to very confident she
keeps it on
when she's at home for some odd reason
like her friends are like
why are you still cruella you don't need
to be it's us it's like if bruce wayne
was going around
wayne manor acting like batman to alfred
alfred
i need my laundry done oh for [ __ ]
sake mr wayne you're bossing me around
like you're bruce wayne but you're still
wearing the bloody mars
my real face is the mask this mask
is my real face mask not my mask face
and getting to the fact that she doesn't
feel like cruella developed she doesn't
in fact emma thompson
plays cruella deville she plays a better
and more accurate cruella deville than
emma stone does and it's not an emma
stone
definitely a conscious effort because
you know they were like all right these
disney
villain origin stories are doing well
but we can't actually make them
[ __ ] i mean come on think of the
children but
you know people want to see cruella
deville in the movie
so we'll make another character that's
not cruella de vil that's a more
accurate cruella development and the
reason that's a weird problem for me is
it's a problem
when an origin story of a character
doesn't end up feeling like the
character you know like
take joker for example i know and i feel
like you're going to hear a lot about
joker i feel like a lot of reviews are
going to be like villain origin story so
uh speaking of joker you're just going
to talk about jokers i i'm going to
touch on joker too but with joker
you knew that this guy was on the path
to being joker you knew this guy was in
the larval
phase of becoming the person who will
beat robin with a crowbar do all the
things we knew joker did and by the end
of the movie you're like yes he feels
like joker that's
that was a joker origin story by the end
of cruella i was like this
makes zero sense because she didn't feel
like cruella deville
she doesn't feel like cruella deville so
why even make it a cruella movie and i
think that is
with the times like i said in the pitch
room
superhero or disney property tie it into
one of both she feels as much like
cruella deville by the end of this movie
as arthur fleck would feel like joker
if he went on the murray show didn't
shoot murray and then
joined the peace corps you know like
it's just like i guess it's a joker
origin story because you told us
but it doesn't feel like that and that's
how this is it feels like a cruella
deville origin story because
they told us it is but it doesn't feel
like a cruella de vil origin story that
said this is where i'm gonna leave it
off cause i feel like this video is
dragging on a bit too
long this movie has enjoyment in it has
a flair
style to it emma stone and emma thompson
carry the movie and they're the ones who
bring that fun to the forefront and all
that fun has to do with the characters
interacting the tension with the
characters what hobbles this movie
hamstrings it
brings it down is the fact that they try
to crush it into this box
that is disney villain origin story and
that's where the movie's not as
interesting
there's actually a pretty fun movie in
here though be it it's a bit too long
but there is something fun
in here and i suppose i just walked away
from this movie annoyed at the fact that
this movie just
had to be a cruella de vil movie when it
didn't that said
while i was enjoying this movie i did
have beer in hand so i'm gonna go with
the dad on this one data says this
movie's a pretty fun time
if you're drunk yeah now it's a party
killer soundtrack too i thought the
soundtrack in this movie was great would
have felt wrong ending this video not
touching on the soundtrack cause i like
the music all right so
cruella have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you